- [Narrator] If you think of blight,
you probably don't picture something
like this parking garage,
but New York considers it blighted.
That's because blight is a word
with more than just a
negative connotation.
It has the power to
unlock billions of dollars
for real estate development
by opening the door
for governments to seize
private property for public use.
Just look at New York's $40 billion plan
for Penn Station or LA's $2
billion Angels Landing project.
Even Seattle's famous
Pike Place was transformed
from this to this on the basis of blight.
- It can be the basis for deciding
that the area should be
condemned and redeveloped.
- [Narrator] But these
redevelopment projects don't hinge
on the same interpretation
of blight, just the word.
Here's why blight is so tough to define,
how it's used to redevelop cities,
and why its use is a
source of heated debate.
Blight has been blamed for
increasing crime, drug use
and unsanitary conditions
in neighborhoods across the country
but the standard isn't the
same across every legal code.
Take Pittsburgh as an example.
Here blight could be a building used
for an immoral purpose.
In Columbus, Kansas,
foot-tall weeds check the box.
In Washington State, being
a menace to the public
was the rationale used
to classify this motel
as blighted in 2015.
- What is your standard that
you use to determine blight?
- Blight, it's a difficult
term to define precisely
because it's used in a
lot of different ways.
- Amy Lavine specializes in
land use and municipal law.
- She has exceptional knowledge
in the area of eminent domain
and was integral in
drafting our legislation.
- In general, it's used
to identify the land
that should be part of
a redevelopment area.
- [Narrator] And once land
is identified as blighted,
the stage is set for eminent domain,
giving the government the
power to seize the property.
- If the government needs to
build a school or build a road,
they can go in and they can take property
from private property owners
and then use it to provide
those public purposes.
- [Narrator] New York and the agency
in charge of the Penn Station project,
Empire State Development,
are using eminent domain
after deeming these blocks as blighted,
the conclusion of a neighborhood study.
in the spring of 2020.
Some of what Empire State
Development called blighted
includes this building
with its missing windows, cracked curbs
and ADA inaccessibility.
This white storefront was cited
for its stained windows,
scaffolding and cracked sidewalks.
- Empire State Development
needs to meet certain conditions
to be involved in a project
and they do that by making a finding
that the property is
substandard and insanitary.
- [Narrator] Then the state
can slate the buildings
for redevelopment using eminent domain.
- This Penn Station
development is crucial for us.
- [Narrator] On these eight lots,
the state is proposing new skyscrapers,
which it says will help
fund major improvements
to Penn Station,
as well as cosmetic upgrades
like cleaning up these drains
and the stained walls.
But governments across the US
have used eminent domain for decades.
Just look at Seattle.
In the late 1950s,
city officials started
declaring neighborhoods blighted
and began redevelopment.
- Your city is engaged in
dramatically revitalizing several
of our older neighborhoods.
- [Narrator] Some residents
said blight designations
targeted low income
neighborhoods and minorities.
That project faced opposition
back when it started.
In a letter, one resident
called it "grossly unfair,"
and almost 60 years later,
Seattle passed a resolution
on how the forced acquisition
of a church property,
which occurred as part of that project
heard the local Black community.
Today that land is part of a city park.
- A lot of people think
that urban renewal is over
and not still happening,
and so they call them different things.
In the case of Barclays Center,
or Penn Station, it's
economic redevelopment.
- [Narrator] And relocation still occurs.
These are all the businesses
that might be displaced
by the Penn Station project.
It's the main reason
why some people living
and working in the Penn
Station area are opposed.
Although relocated residents
are given just compensation
or fair market value for their property.
- I think people do, in a lot of cases,
get the sense that the basis
for the condemnation is
a little bit subjective.
- [Narrator] Residents in
the Penn area are responding
in similar ways as Seattle
residents, 80 years later.
One lawyer even filed a lawsuit
to urge New York to
disclose communications
with real estate developer Vornado,
the largest private
stakeholder in the project.
One watchdog group estimated
that Vornado may receive up
to $1.2 billion in subsidies
during the project.
Vornado declined to comment.
Empire State Development said
that Hochul's proposal is what New Yorkers
and Penn Station deserve.
- So the main part of the lawsuit,
it is about the issue of blight.
The way the law is set up doesn't
make it particularly easy.
- [Narrator] A government's
ability to use blight
to seize property has been
challenged in the past.
One case even reached the
Supreme Court in 2005,
which held that governments
can take property
for the purpose of promoting
economic development.
- Economic development is a traditional
and long-accepted function of government,
- [Narrator] As construction
begins in the Penn Station area
so will the legal cases against it.
(pensive music)